[Music]  this week the FDA announced they're  finally updating the nutritional label  found on all packaged foods I'm talking  about this thing here you see it on  every single box or a package or  anything when you go to the grocery  store well the new label still shows  things like calories okay and sugar  right but now it also includes things  that weren't previously disclosed for  example sugars that were added gonna be  in there now and sugars that snuck in  when we weren't looking check this one  out factory employee DNA going to be in  there yeah check out this one yeah  check out this whatever [ __ ] that was  speaking of the achievement look at this  one chances this product will give you  diarrhea look at this this one's crazy  look at Alex Trebek  [Applause]  you